so have you heard the good news yet that
Team Four Star are finally coming back
to do the boo Saga
sort of
Nate I teased this at the end of my most
recent cell Arc review on YouTube what
the hell heaven actually
and basically from my boo Saga review I
reached out to Team Four Star and asked
if they could make one clip for my
review you know like they did for the
last big review I did of the early
Dragon Ball material instead they came
back and produced a big chunk of Clips
to supplement the video with they've
already announced that there will be
around 28 minutes total of Clips across
the review and let me tell you is good
so prepare yourself part one of two
drops this Saturday y'all ain't ready